yeah and I have hero of the day today
Leon congratulations such a big fight
and finally you managed to win this game
what happened at the very beginning and
what you think were the critical moments
I think you got nice position yeah I I
think uh I looked at something like that
with my second uh Aram hopan uh but I
didn't really remember what I had
intended but I think this all makes
perfect sense you know I'm just
developing and uh yeah I felt C5 is very
strange I I thought C5 is um is not the
move because after that somehow you
know um I mean if he has to play D5 then
something to be good for yeah probably
he can take on C3 and then just but uh I
think uh maybe it's more precise to take
one move mhm so I think was let's go for
some critical moments I think there were
so many in this game so you push this D6
I think it was really important yes to
get rid of this pawn and took on
surprised by Queen E7 I thought Rook fc8
or Rook A8 some sort of you know it's
tiny bit better for me but it's not the
end of the world because after this it
felt really comfortable for me you know
because Queen comes to F3 and I felt it
should be a very nice position for me
yeah and then Knight D4 of course was
surprising I I mainly looked at Knight
D5 and I thought you know it's a tiny
bit better Pleasant position you know
you can play
Forever and after Knight A4 I think this
is a very nice position for white yes
yes yes everybody agrees with you but
but I think it was actually this moment
when he played F5 which made his
position even worse yes no I saw that I
can take and play Rook D7 but Queen B8 I
wasn't so sure I I can immediately
benefit from it you know I felt that
this is kind of a critical thing if
either I take or but Knight C4 felt kind
of a move that should be unpleasant in
time trouble for my opponent yeah you
had many choices at this position
actually when it's good it's hard
actually to make the choice yes no
because I felt A4 is such a risky move
you know strategically you know this
always is hanging I have this queen D3
F3 ideas maybe concretely I I blundered
something it's quite possible but uh did
you feel at any moment that you know
wind was slippering or
say which was this
moment yeah I think somewhere here
somehow uh I underestimated this Rook B8
and I felt uh you know um it's it's a
very good position but it's not that
easy after Knight C6 but still I was cuz
I was in time trouble I felt you know if
I play Slowly I might not get the chance
so here I felt but it's you know it's
not type of a position that is very
pleasant for black to play exactly I
mean you have a bone up yeah I mean and
you can play it forever and of course I
should ask you about this moment when he
he made the movies one second on CL I
mean did you notice what did you feel at
this no I didn't notice because notice I
left ah you were not there no I was not
there but when you came back and saw 31
seconds did you notice that you didn't P
yes he made it like Rook C4 and it was
move number 40 and we know that this is
the move where you do normally mistakes
right yeah I think Rook C4 was probably
a mistake but Rook B5 generally is an
unpleasant move that I made you know
just to make him come up with that
decision this I'm not sure if this is if
what what this position is because I
really don't know okay Peter you played
actually very well Peter showed us many
many lines and I think you played really
really good from this point and finding
the more or less the only lines and
maybe you just can show couple of
moments where you it was very surprising
you know that this is actually is
winning I felt that
here uh
wait yes uh that here I somehow started
remembering and I couldn't remember it
fully because I thought I think the Rook
is on the short side so maybe this is
losing let's say King B5 doesn't matter
King G3 Rook h8 I mean it's of course
embarrassing not to remember I mean this
is a basic position but I somehow
remembered something like this and here
King C6 King F6 I think oh this is a
draw yeah Rook E4 I mean oh no
wait Rook E2 and uh King C6 ah E5 yeah
Rook is on the Short Line yeah Rook is
on a short file so itn't I mean after
five hours of play I mean you you're you
can forget anything you want you know
King F7 King F6 so but if if the if the
king is here and The Rook is there it's
a dead dra yes okay yeah but because of
the Rook here but it's uh I I was kind
of shocked that I have to to reserve to
this and here of course I think H3 is
the only move I felt mhm maybe something
else is winning too but I felt I need to
play this in order to have this uh Rook
C4 business but here you know I I was
very
shaky yeah I can imagine but I mean to
win such a game which actually now you
have plus one it's complicated with the
standings but do you feel as a leader
now of the
tournament co-leader well it's hard to
tell but uh you know winning a a
classical game is always a Wonder as my
friend Boris gon said and I I agree with
him even more so nowadays so you need to
make a little Wonder to win and uh yeah
I'm very happy I manag exactly this what
happened thank you so much Leon have a
good rest tomorrow we have a free day
all the best in the next games thank
very much thank you Anastasia thank you
for Leon and indeed that move H2 h